je venais d'avoir onze ans les élèves à
l'école se moquer de moi parce que
j'étais le petit nouveau
on se parlait quasiment plus ma mère et
moi tous mes rêves s'était envolé le
seul auquel je pouvais me raccrocher
c'était john vous entendez la traduction
mais si le premier film anglophone de
xavier dolan au canada enfin enfin enfin
parce que le tournage eu lieu en 2016 en
xavier dolan a été en salle de montage
qu'on a environ deux ans c'est
finalement festival du film de toronto
l'année dernière que le film a été
diffusé en première mondiale et les
sorties en salles en france en mars
dernier les critiques nord-américaine
assez peu positive assez négative alors
qu'en france on disait un des meilleurs
films de xavier dolan qu'en est il c'est
entre les deux en fait c'est loin d'être
un avis mais c'est le moins bon film de
xavier dolan s'ils sont moins emballante
et sont moins excitant mais il ne pas
avoir honte de ce film là et c'est
étonnant de constater qu'à pas de
distributeur aux états unis pour ce film
là alors que c'est un film en anglais
qui met en vedette de nombreux super
star oscarisée avec un trio de
comédienne oscarisée natalie portman
kathy bates ou sardine kit harington que
le personnage principal de john f dans
le veulent bien connu pour son dans game
of thrones il joue le rôle d'une vedette
d'hollywood qui répondent aux lettres
d'un jeune garçon
les deux ne se connaissent pas ils ne se
sont jamais rencontrés mais il y aura
correspondance entre les deux pendant
des années lorsque cette correspondance
éclater au grand jour
ça suscite toute une controverse et sam
est en quelque sorte fin à sa carrière
donc c'est un film qui dans la première
partie est beaucoup trop sage beaucoup
trop conventionnel et prend beaucoup de
temps pour mettre en place ses
personnages l'histoire alors qu'on
comprend les enjeux y occuper le premier
montage quatre heures finalement le film
fait un peu moins de deux heures et on
si bizarre parce qu'il fait mes
personnages en très gros plan et on se
sent loin de ces personnages-là l'eau il
se passe quelque chose dans la dernière
partie lorsque xavier dolan réalise
enfin ce qu'il fait le mieux
créer des scènes d'intensité
hallucinante entre deux personnages que
je suis lui qui peut faire une scène
aussi puissante entre une mère et son
fils il réussi mon vrai merveilleusement
bien encore une fois moi je me suis
retenue pour ne pas pleurer au moins à
deux reprises dans ces moments là mais
on sent qu'ils eurent et écrire son
scénario en salle de montage des
personnages qui sont vraiment évacuer
qu'on voit très peu dans celui de katy b
c'est en salles partout au pays
il n'accorde aucune entrevue au québec
pour la sortie de ce film là il se garde
pour son prochain film en français qui
va sortir en octobre
mathias et maxime et on aura dans
quelques jours les premières images la
première bande annonce de ce prochain
film français de xavier dans la rivière
merci tête à merci